MALE SPEAKER: All
right, hey everyone.
Thank you so much
for coming out.
I'm super-excited to introduce
our speaker today Jia Jiang.
Jia Jiang is the author
of "Rejection Proof.
It's his story of 100
days of rejection.
So to conquer his
fear of rejection,
he actually actively sought
out different rejections.
And he had all these
crazy little kind
of stories going along with it.
So he is also a viral superstar.
He has over five million
views on one of his YouTubes.
So that's going to
be one of his videos
that he might show you today.
And he's also a member
of our Google family.
His wife is actually one
of our program managers
in G-tech consumers.
So without further
ado, please help
me give Jia Jiang a very,
very warm Googley welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
JIA JIANG: Charles said
that the introduction
would be 30 seconds--
actually really good on time.
So you did a good job too.
So if I come here
and tell you, hey, I
found a solution to one
of your biggest problems
you'll find in
life, whether that's
your professional
career, academic career,
or personal life.
What are you going to say to me?
You might be like, yeah right.
What are you trying to sell?
Well, you might
reject me right here.
But rejection is precisely
what I'm talking about.
It's the fear of
rejection that's
one of the biggest problems
we'll find in life.
it's a terrible fear that,
yeah, keeps us in line,
makes sure people like
us, and makes sure we
don't do anything crazy.
But it's also the
type of fear that
might keep you asking
from what you want,
getting what you need, and
sometimes even achieving
your dreams.
And I did find that solution.
But before I go there, I'll tell
you a little bit about who I am
and precisely the
two versions of me--
we're Silicon Valley,
the two version.
So the version 1.0
is all about gifts.
Who doesn't like them, right?
Well, when I was a
six-year-old, I got my gift.
I was in elementary school.
My first grade teacher
had a brilliant idea--
brilliant--I'm using air quotes.
She wanted us to experience
receiving gifts as well
as learning the virtue of
complimenting each other.
So she had all of us come
to the front of the class.
And she bought all of
us gifts just like that
and stacked them in the corner.
And she said, why
don't we come here
and just compliment each
other and say nice things.
And if you hear your name
called by another student,
you go pick up your
gift and sit down.
What a great idea, right?
What could possibly go wrong?
Well, when he started,
there were 40 of us.
And every time when
someone's name was called,
I would give the
hardiest cheer whether it
was a good student helpful
to teachers and whatever.
And I would just applaud.
And then there were 20 left,
10 left, 5 left, and 3 left.
And I was one of them.
And the compliments stopped.
At that time I didn't want
to compliment anymore.
I didn't want my gift anymore.
I just wanted to sit down.
And I was just crying.
And the teacher though--
she was just freaking out.
And she was like would
anyone say anything nice
about these people?
No one?
OK, why don't you
go pick up your gift
and sit down so you behave
better next year-- someone will
say something nice about you.
So that was one version of me.
And I would die now to be in
that situation again getting
embarrassed in front of people.
That's my first
public rejection.
Then fast forward eight
years-- when I was 14.
I grew up in
Beijing, by the way.
And this guy came to
my hometown to speak.
And I heard him talk.
I was in the
audience-- Bill Gates.
I know he's not
that popular here.
But at the time, he was it.
And by the way, I have no
idea why this pictures is in
black and white.
It is 20 years ago.
It wasn't like in
World War II days
or General Patton was
sitting there or something.
But I guess I didn't have any
Android or iPhone back then.
But he came to my
home town to speak.
I was just mesmerized by
his idea-- by his story.
I loved his idea of using
technology to change the world.
And I just want to be like him.
And that night I wrote a letter
to my family and telling them,
hey, by age 25, I will build the
biggest company in the world.
And I will buy Microsoft.
I just solely embraced this
idea of dominating the world
and buying everyone.
And then I didn't make this up.
I did write that letter.
And here's that letter.
The first line says, no, I'm not
going to go through this line
by line.
But I did highlight
some key words
so you know what
I'm talking about.
In that letter, I also wrote I
will come to the United States
someday to fulfill that dream
because, well, first of all,
that's where Bill Gates lived.
Bill Gates was cool.
I wanted to be where he lives.
But also, remember
that year there
was a movie that was called
"True Lies" that came out.
And that was my-- still my
favorite movie of all time.
In that movie, Arnold
Schwarzenegger he
was like jumping through
buildings on horseback
and hanging on helicopters
and saving the world.
And I am like that's America.
That's where I want to be.
So I came when I was 16 under
a cultural exchange program
as a cultural exchange student.
And so I thought that's
the start of my dream--
my entrepreneur dream.
And then fast forward
another 14 years.
I was 30.
And I did not build the
biggest company in the world.
I didn't even start.
And even at work, I
feel very stagnant.
I just felt-- I
mean, from outside
I was doing pretty fine.
I was working in one of the
biggest companies in the world.
And I was collecting
good income.
A lot of people were
asking me for jobs.
But then I-- but I still didn't
do the things I wanted to do.
I didn't go after my dreams.
Even at work, every time I
feel like I have a new idea--
every time I want to make
a new proposal-- every time
I want to speak in a
group-- every time I want
to step up and do
something, I just
felt there was this constant
battle between the six-year-old
and the 14-year-old.
One wanted to change the world.
Another was afraid of rejection.
And every time that
six-year-old won out.
And so I just feel maybe
I missed the boat-- maybe
I got too old.
And so I started my-- this
fear of rejection even extended
after I started my own company.
I started my own
company when I was 30.
If you're going
to be Bill Gates,
you got to start
sooner or later, right?
So I started my company.
And four months
into my venture, I
was rejected with
the investment.
And I was hurt.
I was hurt so bad that I
wanted to quit right there.
I was just having-- I just
thought this six-year-old was
whispering in my ear again.
Who do you think you are?
Start ups are for the
geniuses like Bill Gates
and Steve Jobs or Larry Page.
You are just a wanna be.
And your friends are
going to laugh at you.
And your in-laws are going to
hate you probably even more.
So you should quit and
stop embarrassing yourself.
And that's where
it clicked for me.
And I thought would
Bill Gates give up
after a simple investment
rejection like that?
Would any successful
entrepreneurs
give up after rejection?
Would anyone successful in
their career give up like that?
No way.
So I have to really put
this six year old back
to his place once and for all.
I cannot let him
dictate my life anymore.
So I found how can I do this?
How can overcome this
fear of rejection
that's been bothering
me my whole life?
So I searched online.
Google was my friend.
I just googled how do I
overcome the fear of rejection.
And then I came
up-- first of all,
I came up with a bunch
of psychology articles
about where the pain and
fears are coming from.
That didn't say anything to me.
Then I ran through a bunch of
inspirational ra ra articles
that talks about, hey, don't
take rejection personally.
Just overcome it.
And I'm like who doesn't
know that already?
If it's that simple, why
was that hurt this bad.
And then I came to a website.
It's called
rejectiontherapy.com.
How many of you have heard of
rejection therapy, by the way?
No one.
Someone has to.
OK, I'll explain this to you.
Rejection therapy is a game.
It's a card game.
It was started by this
Canadian guy-- an entrepreneur.
His name is Jason Comely.
And so, basically,
it's a game that
is a flash card
game that asks you
to look for rejection every day
instead of avoiding rejection.
So they give you a
30-day challenge.
So every day it asks you to
get rejected at something--
maybe just ask strange stuff.
But in 30 days,
you get rejected.
But after 30 days, you
became like a badass
because you desensitize yourself
from the pain of rejection.
And I just loved this idea.
I thought I'm going to do this.
I'm going to do this not only
for-- not just for 30 days.
And I'll do this for 100 days.
And I'll come up with my
own rejection attempt.
I'm not going to listen to
what a flash card tells me
because I have a little
bit of an authority issue.
And so I'm just
using my imagination
to come up with my
own rejection attempt.
And I will do this for 100 days.
And I will use my
phone to film it.
And I'll put it on YouTube
to make a video blog or vlog.
And also, I will tell
the world about it
so they will hold
me accountable.
Otherwise, I would probably
just quit pretty quickly.
So this is what I did.
This is what the
website looked then.
Maybe you can see
rejection one--
borrow $100 from a stranger.
I was working in
this big building
in Austin Texas at the time.
And I just one day
I finished work.
I came down I saw this big
guy sitting behind a desk.
He looked like a security guard.
So I just approached him and
as I was a walking toward him,
I could just feel the hair
at the back of my neck
was standing up.
I was sweating.
My heart was pounding.
And as he came, I said, hey,
can I borrow $100 from you?
And he looked up me
and was like, no, why?
And I just turned around
and just said, I'm sorry.
I just ran as fast as I could.
I just felt so embarrassed.
And that night--
but you got to--
because I was doing the
video because I filmed myself
with my phone, I had to
experience this twice.
So that night I
was seeing myself.
I had to upload the
video on YouTube, right?
And I just saw myself
frame by frame.
I just saw how scared I was.
I looked like this kid from
the movie "Sixth Sense."
I saw dead people.
And then I saw this guy.
He was a chubby looking guy.
But he was pretty lovable.
He wasn't menacing.
And he didn't pull out a club.
He didn't use pepper
spray or call the police.
He was just saying no.
And he asked me why.
In fact, he was inviting
me to explain myself.
I could have said many things.
I could have said,
well, I'm trying
to overcome my
fear of rejection.
That's why I'm
trying to do this.
Or I could have
said, OK, I'm just
trying to try something new
to see if it's possible.
If you give me $100 and trust
me, I'll give you $110 back.
That's 10% rate of return.
You're not going to get that
in the stock market in one day.
And I worked upstairs.
If you don't trust me,
here's my driver's license.
I could have negotiated.
I could say if
you can't do $100,
I can do $50--
something like that.
But I didn't do any of that.
I just ran as fast as I could.
And I'm like, wow, this
is a microcosm of my life.
Every time I get
rejected at something,
I would just run because
it was so painful for me.
So I said the next day,
no matter what happens,
I'm not going to run.
I'll stay engaged.
And I'll chat.
So rejection two--
request a burger refill.
Of course, I didn't
work at Google.
So you can pull this off here.
You get free burgers
if you are here.
But I went to a burger joint.
And after having a very
juicy burger for lunch,
I went to the cashier and said,
hey, can I get a burger refill?
I was like what's
a burger refill?
Just like a drink refill,
but with a burger.
And he was like, sorry, we
don't do burger refills, man.
And so this is where
the rejection happened.
And I could have just ran
right there like I did before.
But this time I stayed.
I said, well, I love you burger.
It's so good.
If you guys do burger refills,
I'll love you guys even more.
And I'll come back
here every day.
And it was like, oh, thank
you for the compliment.
But sorry, we can't
do a burger refill.
I'll tell my managers.
And maybe we'll do it someday.
I don't think they ever did
burger refills because I think
that restaurant is still there.
But when I left that day, that
life and death feeling-- it
was still awkward.
It was still weird.
I was still nervous.
But that life and death
feeling was not there anymore.
So I thought, wow, great!
You know, two days in, I'm
already learning stuff.
If I just don't run,
things can happen.
And I just-- I don't have to
feel the fear if I just stay
engaged.
Then something happened--
like something strange--
really strange happened.
People started to say yes to me.
And more than once.
So, for example, let me
see-- rejection six-- play
soccer in someone's backyard.
All right, so one day
I held a soccer ball
and knocked on a stranger's
door with my cleats
and shin guards all decked out.
And I knock on the
door and said, sir,
can I play soccer
in your backyard?
And he came out .
And he had this giant
Texas flag on his t-shirt.
People do that in
Texas, you know?
And he was like
soccer in my backyard?
Then he saw I was all serious.
He saw my cleats.
And he was like, I guess so.
All right, come on in.
I was just confused as ever.
So I went into his backyard
and just bounced the ball
with my foot and had him
take a picture of me.
So before leaving I said,
how can you say yes?
And he said, this is so off
the wall, how can I say no?
OK, then one day I--
one day I was driving.
I saw a police car.
And I was-- I flagged him down.
I pulled the police
officer over for revenge.
And I said, officer,
can I drive your car.
And he was-- I'm not
going to drive it away
because if I do that, I'll
probably get in trouble.
But can I just sit there
and listen to your radio
and feel like a police
officer and give it a spin?
And he was like, OK, you
look pretty harmless.
Sure.
So I got in a police car.
And then-- in the
front, by the way.
In the driver's seat.
It would be different if
I was in the backseat.
And then one day I said
what is something that's
so impossible that
someone would-- there's
no way I would get a yes?
How about flying a plane?
By the way, I had no license
or courage or knowledge
to fly a plane.
But I went to an
airfield in Austin.
And I talked to this pilot
guy in the in the lobby.
I said, sir, can
I fly your plane?
And he was so happy.
He was like, yeah, come on in.
Come on in.
I'll teach you how to fly.
I'm like, why?
And it turned out he
didn't own a commercial jet
liner or something.
He owned a gyro plane.
It's like a small plane--
like a miniature helicopter
type of thing-- or maybe
like a motorcycle in the air.
And he's an
enthusiast-- a hobbyist.
And he wanted to show everyone
his awesome gyro plane.
So he was so happy
that I approached him.
And then there's one day that
my life got turned upside down.
It's never been the same sense.
Day three-- ask for
Olympic symbol donuts.
How many of you
have seen the video?
Raise your hand.
A few of you.
OK, most of you haven't.
OK, I got to show
the video then.
I'll show the full version.
We'll have some time.
I'm driving to a Krispy Kreme.
I'm going to,
well, I don't know.
I just got my hair
cut yesterday.
I look like a Viet
Cong from the 1960s.
It's OK.
I'm going to grow
into it or my hair
is going to grow
into me either way.
I'm driving toward Krispy Kreme.
I'm going to ask them to make
me some specialized donuts.
And we'll see what happens.
JACKIE: What kind of specialized
donuts are you talking about?
JIA JIANG: I'd like
to have-- getting--
you link the five
donuts together and make
them look like Olympic symbols.
JACKIE: And when are
you looking for these?
JIA JIANG: Huh?
JACKIE: When?
JIA JIANG: The next 15 minutes.
JACKIE: How did they
link them this year?
JIA JIANG: Just normal.
Normal color is fine.
JACKIE: You want them linked?
JIA JIANG: Yeah.
JACKIE: I don't know
if we can do that.
I've got it-- because I
didn't even pay attention
to the Olympics this year.
JIA JIANG: No, just you got
the five donuts together that
look like an Olympic symbol.
JACKIE: Was it
this way this year?
JIA JIANG: Something like that.
That will work.
Just link any five
donuts together.
It's going to be awesome.
JACKIE: It's going
to take me longer.
JIA JIANG: How long?
JACKIE: Because I've got to
catch them on the other side.
And then they've got to
go through the proofer
and then drop in the fryer.
And it was the red,
blue, green, yellow--
what's the other color?
JIA JIANG: Red, green,
yellow-- blue-- maybe white?
JACKIE: Is it white?
JIA JIANG: Could be?
JACKIE: That sounds right.
Oh, my gosh, I haven't watched
the Olympics in so long
that-- I may not be able to
link them, but maybe make them
look like they are interlinked.
JIA JIANG: OK.
That would be great.
JACKIE: The only thing
I'm worried about
is if i try to put those
through the proofer,
they will unsettle the glaze.
And they'll end up falling.
And then once they hit the
fryer, you've got a divider.
And if they hit that, they
are going to get stuck.
You know what I'm saying?
JIA JIANG: If you could make
that, it will make my day.
JACKIE: Red, yellow,
green, blue, white, right?
JIA JIANG: Yep.
JACKIE: I am going
to see what I can do.
JIA JIANG: OK.
JACKIE: I tried, but
what do you think?
JIA JIANG: Wow!
That is really good.
Yeah.
JACKIE: That's the best I
could do with what we've got.
JIA JIANG: No, it's good.
It's good.
It's more than I
thought would be done.
So great!
All right.
So Jackie?
JACKIE: Yes.
JIA JIANG: All right, I'm a fan.
Thank you.
JACKIE: You're way too kind.
JIA JIANG: No, no.
JIA JIANG: You're really good.
All right, so do I pay there.
JACKIE: Don't even
worry about it.
That one's on me.
JIA JIANG: Are you serious?
JACKIE: Get out.
Get out.
JIA JIANG: Are you serious?
JACKIE: Very.
Extremely.
JIA JIANG: Wow!
JACKIE: Extremely.
That's my pleasure.
JIA JIANG: All right, Jackie.
I'll take it.
But man, you're making
me really happy today.
All right, thank you.
JACKIE: Very welcome.
JIA JIANG: See you.
Give me a hug.
JACKIE: Enjoy.
JIA JIANG: All right, thank you.
See you.
JACKIE: Very welcome.
JIA JIANG: Wow!
Sometimes you make
a crazy request,
you get an awesome answer.
Jackie who works for Krispy
Kreme in Austin, Texas,
thank you.
You are awesome.
As for me, I failed miserably
because I did not get a no.
All right, there are
97 more days to go.
Hopefully there are more nos.
Or hopefully there
are more like this.
It just delights your heart.
This is what it looked like.
That night we had
that for dinner.
By the way, it was
pretty sweet-- too sweet.
But it felt sweeter--
the experience.
By the way, when
that was happening,
I remember Tracy was calling me.
And she was like,
hey, dinner's ready.
I'm like, hey, just
hold on, honey.
Something amazing is happening.
So I just couldn't believe
the customer service
or human kindness that
was shown in that movie.
If you own a business,
don't you want
to hire someone like Jackie
to run your business?
And the world couldn't
believe that either.
When I uploaded this
video on YouTube,
it got over five million
views in a few days.
And it was on the front page
of like some newspapers-- front
page of Yahoo.
It was on Reddit.
It was on newspapers--
media across the world.
And "Business Week" even
flew a reporter down
to find out what I was
doing looking for rejection.
I used to think I
love "Business Week."
It was my favorite magazine.
I used to think I got to
build this great company.
And I got to become this
famous guy or something
to actually be on "Business
Week" It happened that day.
But the thing is some sort of
internet fame didn't really--
is not what I wanted.
What I wanted was really helping
myself to overcome my fear.
But also I wanted
to do research.
I want to find out
what is rejection?
I want to turn this
into a playground
and to experiment on every
theory I have read in books
and have heard how to negotiate
and how to communicate.
And, also, I was
hearing stories--
because this video went
viral, I was getting emails
and social media comments from
people from all over the world.
And some of them were
sharing their story with me.
And they were
saying somehow what
I was doing was
inspiring to them
as if they are living
through this-- their own fear
through my eyes.
So, for example, there's
an artist in Austin, Texas.
And she saw this video.
And she was like, oh,
that video is nice.
I love those donuts.
But, hey, I'm a real artist.
She makes art that's
beautiful and profound.
But she didn't share
it with anyone.
She is just like this is my art.
It's my space.
Then she was like if you
can make that video viral,
why shouldn't I share my art?
And she did.
So she shared it was her
friends, family members, even
the local media.
And it got picked up
by national media.
And she was invited
to go to Washington DC
to provide a show.
That was really amazing.
And there was this guy-- he is--
he wanted to go on a rejection
request with me.
He thought this was fun.
He said, can I go with you?
I'm like sure.
So we had this idea
of we go to a bank
and borrow $100 bills to
play paper plane fight.
It wasn't my best idea.
I had better moments.
But when I-- when I-- so
before going in, he was like,
hey, don't worry.
I know what to say.
I have a plan.
At that moment, before
going to the bank
I just hope that plan
did not involve a gun.
So he went in.
And the teller was like that
sounds fun, let's do it.
So we placed some paper
airplanes in the--
at a counter.
And I won, I think.
But after coming out, the
guy was telling me wow,
I never thought this
would be possible.
I never tried this
kind of thing before.
And he started
reflecting on his life.
He was like, I wanted-- I
always wanted to have this job.
I wanted to-- I've been
in sales for 19 years.
And I'm really good at my job.
I am one of the best.
But the thing is I want
to try something new.
And I want-- I don't think
I qualify for this job.
But now I want to
try it and just ask.
I want see what happens.
Not only he got a job-- this
is a Fortune 100 company.
Not only he got a
job, he actually now
he managed the entrepreneur
center of the UK
for this company.
This is his dream job times two.
So I'm like, wow,
what is rejection?
What is this thing
that, by the way,
I have 100 of these videos
where they're all kind of fun
if you can get on
my YouTube and see.
I was thinking is rejection?
What is this thing that
we're all afraid of?
I thought I was the only one
who was afraid of rejection--
maybe a few other people.
And it turned out everyone was
afraid of rejection in some way
no matter how successful they
are or how well they hide it.
But a lot of people were making
some sort of a mindset change.
They started making
some profound changes
in their lives.
So I started putting
research to work
and trying to find
out what rejection is.
And it turned out rejection is
more or less a numbers game.
I made some requests that
were totally outrageous.
And someone of them
would say yes to me.
And I made some requests
that are more like more
or less borderline OK.
And someone will say no to me.
But the thing is if
you want to get a yes,
I just talk to enough people.
One person will
eventually say yes.
It's almost a as every
rejection has a number.
If I just walk through that
number, a no becomes a yes.
Speaking of numbered,
how many od you--
do you like Harry Potter?
How many of you
like Harry Potter?
Raise your hand.
Good, I like a yes.
I love Harry Potter.
Harry Potter is the bestselling
book in modern history.
I'm not comparing
to the Bible or
the Koran or ancient history.
But modern history-- Harry
Potter blows every other book
out of the water.
But you would think a book that
good when it first came out,
it would be something
like a hotcake, right?
That's not the case.
The author, J.K.
Rowling, she had
to go through 12
different publishers
to get her book published.
And every time, they told
her the same the feedback.
they are like, you are trying
to write a children's book
with dark magic and with
the people dying in it,
and this long?
Who's going to read that?
No way.
After the 12th rejection, the
chairman of the publisher,
I mean, he also gave
her the rejection.
But he handed the manuscript
to his granddaughter
who could not put it down.
She refused to eat.
She refused to sleep.
She kept reading and reading
until she finished and totally
exhausted herself.
And the chairman was like,
wow, there's something here.
So he agreed to
publish the book.
And the rest is history.
The thing is to have to J.K.
Rowling given up any of the 12
tries-- had the
chairman not handed
the manuscript with those
to his granddaughter,
there would be no Harry Potter.
And there would not be no big
fight between Harry Potter
and Voldemort at the end.
That would make me really mad.
But think about it.
If Harry Potter had--
if J.K. Rowling had
to go through 12 different
rejections to get
Harry Potter published.
What about ideas come
up from you and me?
And sometimes I feel the ability
to fight through rejection
is almost as important as
coming up with good ideas.
And then rejection
is just an opinion.
I think we need many
things in the world.
Here in California we
need water for sure.
But the world as
a whole-- we need
love sympathy-- more bathrooms
and free drinks, for sure.
But one thing we really
have plenty of is opinion.
Just get on the internet,
turn on your TV.
Everyone has something
to say about something.
And they can't wait to tell
you about their opinion.
I think opinion is probably
the cheapest resource on Earth.
It's also completely
renewable too.
But when it comes
to rejection, it's
nothing more than the preference
and opinion of the rejector.
It actually says more about
the rejector than the rejected.
So when you make
your request known,
the person sizes you up
and says, yes or no to you.
Or maybe it's a group of people.
But that depends a lot
not just solely on you.
It says lot about that person.
It could be him or her that
feed-- the mood of the day.
Maybe it's based on
the education that
come up for a whole lifetime.
Maybe it's his or
her background.
Or maybe it's prejudice.
Who knows?
But somehow when it
comes to rejection,
we think it's all about us.
We think it's some
sort of universal truth
about who we are.
But also it's like an
indictment of our character
or the merit of our idea.
But it's not.
It's really just an opinion.
And that rejection is a tool.
This is a picture of a dumbbell.
I just have to find a
better picture next time.
I'm sorry.
But I often tell people if
someone hands you a weight--
if you don't know
how to handle it,
you're just going to
drop it on your foot.
You're going to hurt
yourself really bad.
Or you try around and run,
you're going to hurt yourself.
But if you know how
to handle rejection,
you can safely put it down
on a rack or on the floor.
And better yet, if you
know how to use rejection
to your advantage,
you can't exercise.
You can use your rejection
to actually gain muscle.
So I did this for 100 days.
Every day I put myself just
outside my comfort zone.
And I went out and asked
and asked and asked.
And gradually my
comfort zone expanded.
And toward the end,
I felt invisible.
I felt I could ask anything
from anyone anywhere.
And so right now
I run online gym
as part of my
business right now is
a gym for the mind
where I challenge people
to go get rejected every day.
And just a couple weeks into
this-- a lot of times people
can just-- they start
asking weird stuff.
They started negotiating
money off their monthly bills.
They started--
some people started
changing their hair color.
They started doing things they
never thought they would do.
It just seems pretty incredible.
And they also have ramifications
in their professional career.
They feel they can--
if they are in sales,
they can sell their
product better.
Or anyone they can sell
their ideas better.
And it's really amazing.
I used to think that your
confidence-- your charisma,
or your courage is really
probably born based
on your personality, right?
But actually,
that's not the case.
In these 100 days, I almost
had a personal transformation.
I became a different person,
I just felt so much more bold.
And I used to hate
the idea of self help.
I still do actually.
I don't think they
do anyone any good.
It's maybe a lot of
late night infomercials.
But in this 100
days, I went through
a personal transformation that
I didn't need any self help
book to work with.
And then rejection is also
a source of knowledge.
So that's why I wrote the
book to share the knowledge.
I want to a pretty
good business school.
And I'm sure a lot of you went
to some of the best schools
in the world.
I thought I learned
a lot about business.
But I can say in this 100
days I probably learned more
about communication
and human nature
than I ever did in business
school or any school
because I put myself out
there talking to real people,
making really negotiations,
being really weird.
And I learned a whole lot.
So, for example,
I'm share some here.
One thing I learned
is you can actually
maximize your chance
to get a yes by telling
the other people a
doubt they might have
or maybe a weakness
you might have
in your argument,
in your request.
So I used to be like if I
want to sell a product-- if I
want to sell an idea or maybe
do a job interview for myself--
I would just say
how awesome I am
and how flawless
this product is.
And this idea would be
the best in the world.
But people have doubt.
And sometimes we don't
even mention the doubt.
They just keep it in their
mind and to your detriment.
And those doubts
will not go away.
But if I mention their doubt
before they would mention it.
Actually, I can totally maximize
my chance of getting a yes.
One day I went to a Starbucks.
And I went in.
And I asked the manager can
I be a Starbucks greeter?
That's from my
days of rejection.
And he was like, what's
a Starbucks greeter?
I'm like, do you know
Walmart greeters?
The people who stand
in front of Walmart.
They say hi to you-- make
sure you don't steal stuff
from them.
I want to try that at Starbucks.
I will give your customers
a Walmart experience
at Starbucks.
I'm not sure that's
a good thing.
Actually, I'm pretty
sure it's a bad thing.
But he was like,
oh, I'm not sure.
I mean he was a really nice guy.
He's like I'm not sure.
I could just see his mind is
churning and then asking him,
is that really weird?
He was like, yeah, it
was really weird, man.
Then as soon as he said that,
his whole demeanor changed.
Our conversation changed.
And he was like, I think
I'll let you do this.
Just please don't get too weird.
Don't try to sell
stuff to my customers.
So for the next hour, I
was a Starbucks greater.
I said hi to every
customer walking in.
I shook hands with them.
I told them about Starbucks
coffee to my best knowledge.
I gave them holidays cheers.
And by the way, I don't know
what your career trajectory is.
But don't be a greeter please.
It was the worst
job I've ever done.
It was just boring.
If they have a Google greater
at the cafeteria, please
don't volunteer.
But he was able to let me do it.
And I mentioned, is that weird?
And the funny thing is by
mentioning is that weird?
I showed one thing.
I wasn't weird.
I showed to him that I'm
thinking just like him.
I know you feel this is weird.
So I can empathize with you.
And over and over again--
this is 100 days of rejection.
If I mention to people I know
I'm asking for a big favor.
I know people don't
usually ask this.
I know this is weird.
If I mentioned that, more than
likely people will say yes
to me because in a way,
I gained their trust
by empathizing with them.
Another thing is I learned
I can turn no into a yes
by asking for some things.
Like, for example, a
magic award is why?
When people say no
to you, ask why?
Always.
So one day I went into-- I went
to knock on a stranger's door.
I had a flower in my hand.
And by the way, I
don't know why I
was knocking on people's doors.
That was fun.
But I said can I plant this
flower in your backyard?
And he was like, plant
flower map backyard sorry
could you do that but
before he could turn away
I said why just
like an mean issues
this older gentleman
was like, well,
I have a dog that would dig up
anything I put in the backyard.
And if you want to
do this, I don't
want to destroy your flower.
If you want to do this,
go across the street
and talk to Connie.
Connie loves flowers.
And so I did.
I knock on Connie's door and
talk to her and her husband.
She was so happy to see me.
And I was like, this
is flower is awesome.
Yeah, let's do it!
So half an hour later, there was
a flower in Connie's backyard.
And but the thing is had I left
after the initial rejection,
I would have thought, OK,
of course she would say no
because this was really weird.
He probably didn't trust me.
You know, I probably wasn't
good looking enough or whatever.
But it turned out
to be none of that.
It's what I offered
did not fit his needs.
He trusted me enough to give me
a referral, using a sales term,
and I converted that referral.
So and then I also learned
that you can actually
say no to people in a nice
way that makes them your fan.
I found out that
it's tougher for me
to say no than get rejected.
It's tougher for
me to reject people
than getting rejected
because there's
a flip side of rejection, right?
If you say no to people, you
are afraid to feel like a jerk.
You're afraid to be
rejected by them in turn.
So it's the same type
of fear, but just a
of flip side of the coin.
And so but I learned
that sometimes you
can say the right thing and
give them the right rejection.
And they can feel pretty good.
So I went through-- tons of--
went though tons of rejections.
Some of the rejections were bad,
meaning will people be mean.
But I was OK.
But there were some rejections
that were really good.
I would just walk
out a huge fan.
So one thing I
learned is you can
act-- when you reject
people, show them
an alternative to get a yes.
So you are showing that
you're not just rejecting them
as a person, but you are
rejecting their request
for a reason.
And you're helping them.
And so one day I went to
a Costco-- love Costco,
by the way.
I went to a Costco and
talked to the manager.
I said, hey, can I speak
over your intercom?
I just want to say
hi to the customers.
And he said, sorry,
can't let you do that.
But I said, I'm a member--
his membership card.
You can check.
I spent thousands of
dollars here every year.
It was like, wow, you're
a really good member.
But if you want to say
nice things about Costco,
we can offer you to write a
column in our magazine called
"Costco Connect."
I'm sure you get
those in your mailbox.
And you can-- we love
the stories from you.
And then so he showed
me an alternative.
And I said, I would really
love to speak on your intercom.
And he's like, are you hungry?
I'm like, excuse me?
He's like, are you hungry?
I'm like, yeah, why?
How about I buy you dinner?
I'm sorry I can't let you do
this-- speak over the intercom.
But I can buy you
pizza and hot dogs
and order whatever you want.
And I walk out with a
full stomach that day.
And I became an even
bigger fan of Costco.
And I spent a lot more
money there afterwards.
So I'm sure those pizza
and hot dogs are worth it.
Of course, that video got viewed
by tons of people as well.
But the thing is not only
he showed me an alternative.
He also made me a concession.
I mean, concession not--
pizza and hot dogs.
That's not what I mean.
But he made a concession
to give me something.
So how can I feel bad when
I get rejected like that?
So there are just a lot
of lessons I learned.
For time-- for reason
of time, there's
one last thing I
just want to share
with you is just two words.
Just ask.
This is the most important
lesson I learned.
I remember, I told you flew
someone's plane right once.
It was awesome.
When I think about
flying, I really
think about just going to the
airport, taking off my belt
and shoes walking through
that security check
and get scanned by
that bone scanner.
And it will give me
cancer some day for sure.
And just charging my phones--
sitting on dirty carpet.
That's my thought of flying.
That day I flew like a bird.
It was awesome.
And just for one minute,
I was a couple feet
above the cornfield.
I felt like a seagull looking
for fish above the ocean.
And next minute I was like
1,000 feet in the air.
There was a cloud all around me.
I was kissing it.
I felt like an eagle.
It was the best flying
experience in my life.
I never thought flying
was possible like that.
But then all this
time, there's only one
thing I could think
about was what
if I hadn't asked this person?
I would not have that
amazing experience.
Then in our lives what
if we don't ask stuff?
Maybe companies
might not be built.
Maybe art may not be shared.
Maybe careers may
not be advanced.
Maybe business
opportunities might be lost.
The reason we don't
ask is because we
think the rejection is something
so painful and so negative.
And there's a biological
reason for that
as well going back to our
ancient hunter and gatherer
days.
But we feel that pain.
We would try everything to
avoid being in that situation.
So we don't ask.
And so by avoiding a negatives,
we're getting positive, right?
That's actually just a
lie we tell ourselves
every day because when we're not
going in there getting rejected
and asking, we're just getting--
we're basically rejecting
ourselves by default. And we're
getting ignored by the world.
So I just tell you,
no matter what,
don't get ignored by the world.
So what's next for me?
Remember, I told you about the
story of getting gifts, right?
Rejection was my
curse-- was my bogeyman.
It haunted my whole
life until into my 30s.
But as soon as I stopped
running away from rejection
and started embracing
rejection, I
turned this into my biggest
opportunity and gift.
I did my blog.
And the blog I was invited
to speak everywhere
to talk to businesses and
people about overcoming the fear
rejection.
I just published my book.
And then I'm even using
technology right now,
mobile technology,
to measure people
how to quantify their fear
and help people to overcome
their fear of rejection.
So it really became
my biggest gift.
So I want to tell you when you
are getting rejected next time
or maybe when you face a failure
or maybe when you are seeing
obstacles, just consider this.
This might be your gift as well.
So thank you guys.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: All
right, so we've
got some time for questions.
So I'll walk over the mic
to if you have anything.
So feel free.
Just raise your hand.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
This has been a great talk.
JIA JIANG: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: One question I had was
you talked about how rejection
is a numbers game.
And you tried all these
different requests.
It also sounds like
maybe the more outlandish
the requests, the likelier
it could be granted.
Did you find any trends around
like what types of requests
usually got accepted
versus rejected?
JIA JIANG: Yeah, it totally
depends on the other person.
Some people are drawn
to the outlandishness.
Some people are
totally risk averse.
They don't want to
deal anything with it.
So it really depends
on this-- it totally
depends on the other person.
I couldn't make the same request
to so 10 different people.
And they gave me-- each one of
them gave me different answers.
So I don't have a
statistical analysis
on the outlandish of the
request versus normalness.
And sometimes it is the reverse.
So I think it really
depends on the other person.
But the idea is the same.
If you ask-- one thing I know.
If I haven's asked, I
would have had no yes.
So, all right.
AUDIENCE: Hi, so
I guess like out
of all these of your
100 days of rejection,
which one is like
the most surprising
or your favorite rejection?
JIA JIANG: I had a
lot of favorites ones.
And also the other
people's favorite ones
when they watch all the video
are different from mine.
Mine was to one day
I walked into OK,
so here's some background.
I come from a
family of teachers--
four generations of teachers.
And it's like my family legacy
is all about being a teacher.
So my grandma once
told me hey, Jia,
you can be anything
you want in the future.
But it would be great
if you were a teacher.
How about that for pressure?
And so but the thing is-- I
don't want to be a teacher.
I want to be an entrepreneur.
I want to do business.
But it's also a dream of
mine to teach a college class
because I want to teach
something and fulfill
that family legacy.
So I said in this 100 days,
I can ask anything I want.
This is my playground.
This is my chance.
So I walk into-- I walk into
UT Austin-- University of Texas
in Austin and started knocking
on professor's doors trying
to teach the class.
And I said, can I
teach your class.
And then a professor
saw-- saw me.
He was intrigued.
He first thought I was
trying to sell him something.
I said, no, I'm not.
But I'm trying to
teach your class.
He was like what?
And then I showed him.
I came in prepared.
I had my tablet with me.
I had my lecture all loaded up.
I was swiping this through.
And said, here's
what I want to teach.
And he was really impressed.
He was like, wow, I can use
this, no one has asked me this.
I can use you in my curriculum.
This is awesome.
So two months later, he
invited me to give a lecture
to his students.
And when I walked
out, I was crying
because I felt this
is something I want
to do maybe later in my life to
build up all of the knowledge
or maybe get a PhD or maybe
I became an accomplishment.
I can do this.
But if I away those
conditioners and just ask,
I made it happen just like that.
So it has inspired me a
lot with that experience.
So that's my favorite.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks,
this is awesome.
JIA JIANG: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have a
two-part question.
So the first is
so when you talked
about being rejection proof,
do you-- did you do anything
to semi-protect yourself
from rejection so
to prepare yourself
for the rejection
when it was happening?
Like you didn't
want to walk away
from the situation
like so hurt or upset
that you couldn't
come back to it.
JIA JIANG: Yeah,
the idea is I want
to be as vulnerable as
possible because I-- OK
the my whole journey changed.
It started with me wanting to
get rejected and feel the pain
and desensitize
myself from the pain.
Do you know iron fist?
That was my idea?
I am going to hit my hand
against the iron stand.
I want to become iron fist.
But then I started seeing
the possibility that people
might say yes to me.
And that changed
my whole paradigm.
That's-- I would just ask.
And I want to see what happens.
And by doing that, I started
putting humor in this.
I started having fun.
And I started not
being afraid anymore.
So that in itself--
the curiosity
actually prepared me for
the rejection that came.
And in the end, also I
learned that rejection is
not-- is really not personal.
It's personal for that
person more for me
because it shows everything
about that person.
There are a lot of Jackies.
There lot of Coscto
managers, but also jerks.
It's OK.
I just learn to deal with it.
AUDIENCE: The other
part of question
was did you notice
that initially you
were leaning towards people
you thought would say yes?
So did you ever have to self
correct as you were doing this?
JIA JIANG: Yeah,
sometimes I'd catch myself
because I wanted to make
sure I don't get off too easy
because you can manipulate
people to say yes to
by lying-- by choosing
an easy target.
But this is too easy.
I'm just like gaming the game.
Getting yes is
not what I wanted.
What I wanted was to
learn from rejection.
So yeah, sometimes I don't
pick the most nice guy.
And I just go--
sometimes I do this game.
I'll talk to the number six guy
walking up through that door,
no matter who that person is.
It could be a police officer.
It could be a homeless
guy-- whatever.
I'll just talk to that guy.
MALE SPEAKER: All right, we've
got about five minutes left.
I want to respect your time
just so there are probably
some of you who want Jia to get
your copy of the books signed
So let's go ahead and
give Jia one last round
of applause. [APPLAUSE]
JIA JIANG: Thank you guys.
Thank you.